Denis starts off this hour in Charlotte
North Carolina
hi Dennis how are you hey Dave a good
thanks and uh thanks for taking my call
certainly sir how can I help okay here's
the deal
my wife and I just bought a house and we
would put 60% down because we just sold
our other house phenomenal so along with
that we picked up a mortgage so I want
to slam the mortgage I'm thinking we got
it we got a 30-year just to get on the
boards
I'm thinking going to a 15-year real
soon and I'm also also provided I can we
can handle that we think you can
provided we can do that I'm also
thinking about taking we got 14 or 15 in
mutual funds and I'm thinking about
taking that out as well and throwing
that on the mortgage as well really get
this thing down how much do you owe
go ahead how much do you owe 132 okay
and what is your interest rate uh
3.6 3.6 85 I just got it we just got it
yeah really interesting so yeah it's a
little high well I thought so
I thought so but we were we wanted to
just get this thing you know done and
get in the house and then start is it a
traditional mortgage it is yeah okay
right um in your household income sir oh
um I'm retired I think we're at about 60
okay you have any money
other than the 14,000 no okay you don't
have a module so you have an emergency
30 is coming in okay you have an
emergency fund of any kind uh yeah yeah
we've got about 20 uh set aside okay all
right in a separate account different
than the 14 correct okay cool yeah I'm
with your plan I would throw the 14 at
it um which gets just you know you know
down in the 1-1 18 or something like
that we got left then and you can put
that on a 15 year normally the only
reason to refinance is not to go from a
to a 15 I wouldn't go to the refinance
cost to do that but in order to save on
interest you would refinance and I think
you could probably save three quarters
of a point I mean I'm seeing quotes I
don't know if you get on mortgage this
small or not but I'm seeing quotes well
down under um under three and so if you
got something like 2.8 75 or 275 or
something like that along those lines
you know that would might be worth
refinancing and then while you're at it
put it on a 15-year and then of course
you just chunk money at it as fast and
as hard as you can like you're saying
and then how do we make that go away
well you make it go away pretty quick
that way you'll probably be done in five
or six years
oh that's now we're talking the same
language yeah okay you just start just
kind of start dividing it you know you
say we're dealing with one hundred and
twenty thousand and you know if we
wanted to do that in ten years that be
ten thousand extra I'm a year uh you
know and if we wanted to do it in five
years that means it'd be 20,000 extra a
year that's right yeah so that's why I'm
saying you know five six seven years
something like that you're probably
going to be done mmm okay can I make one
statement sure one last statement I know
my daughter's listening to this right
now and she'll squeeze blood out of a
rock as far as I her budget goes wanted
to want to tell her that we're gonna mom
and dad are going to take care of her
car payment from here on we're going to
wipe out her debt
no one that just weren't going to use
this opportunity to do that she's not
expecting this but I thought I'd want to
do this but okay Dave thanks very much
that's fun I'm that's first time
anybody's ever announced that on our
show that's very cool
well done sir hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show you can do this you
know that really is a message whether
you've got two hundred seventy thousand
dollars in student loan debt or 27
thousand well you've got a fifty
thousand dollar income a $500,000 income
you